[Music]
okay so why don't you explain this
account i don't i really don't know
somebody i don't even remember sending
this somebody sent me something a tweet
from this account it was really funny
there's someone replying to a woman on
twitter i'm pretty sure that usually
goes well on twitter usually yeah you
notice this young woman sitting at a
cafe table near the beach how do you
open and for those listening it's a
picture of an attractive girl
and someone replies it's beautiful out
and you're a beautiful girl why are you
holed up in here
she blushes
i also noticed some tan lines on your
breasts why don't you and i head out
there to get those fixed up graciously
offer her my hand come on i'll even show
you how i can body surf
i guess what i mean they're all kind of
like what this is not real i no but that
is a gpt-3 response right there
why are your holes full of in this
umbrella yeah you look really nice we
should go check out the new top gun at
the cinema what's up with your boob tan
lines
i'd recommend everyone go see top gun at
the cinema
[Laughter]
your breast meat is two colors
[Laughter]
allow me to tenderize your breasts
[Laughter]
your beautiful supple skin reminds me of
the volleyball scene
a must-see
dude can you imagine being a woman and
then you're just sitting minding your
own business and someone walks up and
says you're a beautiful girl it's a
beautiful day what are you doing hold up
in here yeah you want to see how i can
body surf
no
no
i think i was having a stroke or
something yeah seriously um here's one
this is a dm conversation hey babe
i'm a nice guy unlike other guys i make
you a sandwich
with quivering voice
do you want to go out with me
remember if you reject me it counts as
discrimination as i'm dyslexic
bad bit yeah that's a bad bit
oh my god
oh my god
okay this is a picture of a receipt
the amount is 128 dollars he tips a
thousand so it's a thousand one hundred
and twenty dollars is the total and he
writes beautiful nipples princess call
me
and then he signs it the master at
gentlemen luxury what is that dude you
can read that so many ways beautiful
nipples princess
you are the beautiful nipples princess
you are my beautiful nipple princess
you're like the princess of nipples yeah
yeah you're the princess of all
beautiful nipples
beautiful nipples princess call me
beautiful nipples
[Laughter]
beautiful nipples that's a crazy thing
to say to somebody with a shirt on
yo you have beautiful nipples like how
can you even tell you're the beautiful
nipples princess
you must call me the master
yeah beautiful nipples princess call me
the master
the master dude whenever i see the word
master i just think of the bizanachi
animation where the bog brothers call
they're like get a leak on the line and
then they connect with him and the metal
gear solid [ __ ] and just like ring
master
[Laughter]
pumped once a tattoo then
damn
dump
was good i haven't heard that in a long
time oh no man do that again
listen let's cut all this [ __ ]
i want to put you down on the board and
karate chop your [ __ ]
i want to be the master and i want you
to be my submissive [ __ ] i want to be
your one and only and i want to be the
one you think about before you sleep and
even before you breathe
and i want nothing but to think of the
smell of your hair and to get a wreck
i want that's a crazy way to end it
put this guy by the way all i want is to
get erect at the thought of you that's
it
i don't actually want to do anything
karate chop your [ __ ] read this one oh
my god you're hot as [ __ ] i've been
trying to eat my [ __ ] you just
maybe made me hot enough to try it again
i've been trying to eat my calm is so
good like what does that mean you've
given it multiple attempts and [ __ ]
winnie the pooh just like reaching in
his dick hole
what does that mean though does that
mean like you just can't get any or yeah
maybe i've just been reaching in there
and i can't get anything good reason the
base of this thing yeah it's all out
that's so foul man
this is crazy hey are you on please text
me i'm in pain what my testicles are
swelling i really need to see you in
three normal full body pics of you it's
just ben yeah three pics of ben
oh my god you're tragic please let me
see you your tragic is damn
yeah that's a dunk that is a dunk right
there owned brother next hello my
princess of thorns oh
no
oh no white guy please don't clip me
zayn
[Music]
oh man
is that the same guy
i don't think it's the same guy but i
like to think it is chevy
chevy oh man you ever mess with a white
boy you mess with a white boy no go back
to the princess of the orient would you
by chance be willing to let a white
gentleman scholar colonize
all right all right all right buddy okay
oh dude yes yep yep have you ever hit
slash kicked guys in the nuts before el
well i bet your beauty and captivating
smile would dull most of the pain well
am i wrong or do you hit hard that's
wild that's [ __ ] crazy you want to
get kicked in the balls but like you're
just staring in her eyes my sister just
kicked me as hard as she could squaring
the balls for being in her room [ __ ] i
think one cracked
she says i deserve 10 more kicks then i
should be castrated what do you think
what the [ __ ] fetish is this what i
can't even what what is like what
exactly does he like dude
this guy is shooting from the other
court yeah seriously
is this what it is to be like a 19 year
old woman online you just like log in
and it's just like lol would you kick my
small bee nuts
my sister just slipped my throat what do
you think about that
what damn bro
[Laughter]
unholy union of amazon and whole foods
this is
a tinder profile i want to tongue punch
your fart box all right you being
boosted isn't a positive sign for me
sugar tits certainly not something to
celebrate i find all women to be
beautiful and intriguing creatures that
being said i would really like to date a
nation god damn it stop
why do i have to read these ones
oh you know
the white guys you know they can't stop
man really i'm just tired of white women
i understand why
you women of color can't stand white
women totally right
dude ally
seriously
this dude's an ally
yo you women of color
you women of color
yeah y'all women of color
i understand why y'all can't stand white
women
totally rat unless you're boosted yeah
unless you're boosted that ain't no
positive sign for me sugar tits women
are interesting creatures
horrible they should be put in cages and
studied
you know i'd also really like to date an
asian what is this
no
way dude
what we're done the podcast is over
are you kidding me
i can't breathe i have nothing funny to
say after this you've gotta be kidding
dude
it's a [ __ ] 23andme script i don't
even know you could dm people on 23 and
me what the [ __ ] it's just blank a
relative has sent you a message
less than a third of a percent shared
dna hookup would be okay
holy [ __ ] dude you wouldn't even have
like a profile picture or anything no
right he's just like hey i just want to
hit you up and say i had a good time
with you last night and would love to go
out again sometime i had a good time too
i would love to go out again too but can
i be honest with you for a second uh
sure go ahead i couldn't even believe
you agreed to go out with me oh god i
never imagined it in a million years i
thought that after you would realize
that you made a mistake well now now she
is you [ __ ] oh my god read the next
one
oh yeah no we're good we're good yeah
yeah yeah nah
he's on you
yo this is this is a message from chaz
one of my friends yeah yeah
yeah this is not to a woman this is just
yeah yeah yeah this is just a pledge
yeah what do they call it when there's
like a older frat dude paired with a
younger one big brother
return the favor big bro yeah come on
bro hell yeah i knew you were down do
you want to be in fade aside or nah i do
pee on me next hi i'm sorry to trouble
you but wanted to maybe ask if you
wouldn't mind servicing me i need a soft
tongue to come on do you i don't know i
don't have anything to offer except my
[ __ ] and how grateful for your company
and help would feel tonight i totally
understand if you don't want to though
jesus christ 1 42 am absolute
damn down her rift down her
and we don't even know if he's like on
the east coast you know
it could have been [ __ ] 442.
i need a soft tongue to come on that's
when you know like you've just watched
too much stuff yeah you just been online
to i need a
i just think that's a comment you leave
i don't even know like if you paid like
a only fans person for like a chat yeah
that's where you'd say that maybe like a
webcam room but it's just
in the dms yeah yeah just random people
throw it yeah
sorry
i don't mean to trouble you
why do i say it like that too yeah yeah
yeah i don't mean to trouble you sorry
oh damn yeah
but i i may i inquire for your soft
tongue to come on
please my lady
i just thought about an english dude
getting a head for some chick and he's
just like absolute lad in it
you've just took the whole load you're
allowed oh my god yeah just like [ __ ]
just just talking about her like
she's just one of his boys oh my you've
you've done it yeah
[ __ ] off
you've done it absolute lad oh you're
mental
good lord
you are the nipple princess
[Laughter]
oh lord [ __ ] hell i'm about to finish
[ __ ] hell i'm gonna come in your
[ __ ] throat yeah
you